nichols family here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel
and i got a riddle for you what's got 10
thumbs and it's going to utah
this family
we've got so much camping gear and so
many kids we're needing two cars to get
to the airport nowadays
all right
[Music]
yes
well thank you for picking us up shall
we we appreciate that
all right guys well we're here in utah
for two weeks
and we're gonna be visiting family my
in-laws here are here so
the kids are gonna get to see grandma
and grandpa and we're gonna go out and
do some camping
and we're scuba diving and
catch crawfish fossil hunting
it's gonna be a pretty awesome two weeks
well guys we made it to salt lake city
but it's late i've got a lot of bambinos
to put into bed so i will see you
in the morning well good morning it's 7
30 a.m
and we're already using the first aid
kit
what happened um you were playing with
the treadmill weren't you
yeah so tommy did we learn a lesson
about not playing on treadmills
don't put on full throttle
all right guys got a lovely breakfast
here are you guys hungry
yep yeah well we're gonna go dig up a
whole bunch of fossils today
what are you an egg vampire what are you
doing
nathan what have you taught your brother
this is your side of the family becca
all right we're going fossil hunting out
in the desert it's going to be so hot so
we've got these little
kid-sized camel packs for the boys we're
gonna fill them up with ice and a little
bit of water
and they're gonna have that cold water
resting against their back which will
cool them off
and then of course it'll keep them
hydrated too in the winter time you can
do the opposite and fill your camel back
with hot water and then just wear it
underneath your coat and it'll keep you
super warm
let me look at you guys oh yeah you look
like desert explorers
are guys you ready to dig fossils
oh
[Music]
[Music]
guys we're at you dig fossils near
hinckley utah this is one of the best
places
in the world to find trilobites and
we're gonna find
tons of fossilized trilobites these
things are 500 million
years old and then you guys can grab
some buckets right over here
you guys do you have your buckets yeah
here's our cheat sheet
bronchiopod
this one means it's just the shell and
this one means that it was buried alive
come on boys
there's a little piece so there's a
piece of one right there again and again
so we can't split it anymore i imagine
this is how you guys would end up after
you go to prison
hey becca you find one good
look at that oh look at that yeah
there's a there's a piece of one which
rock did you see
oh my goodness tom look at that look
also look at that one
look at this the size of him there's a
huge
oh check this out that one's whole it's
wholly intact wow that's awesome
what's up baby
there's a piece right there
[Music]
[Applause]
there's there's a little one right there
oh there we go there's some
some pieces right there
look at that it's the whole trilobite
sticking out right there you can see
him hey dude he told me look at this one
hey that's at least that big yeah he's
huge
jacob you found this yeah look at that
that's a title bite shell they shed
their shells and the shells get
fossilized
get up found some crystals look at
though those are pretty
oh yeah jake you having fun yeah
you're tired no you're tired mama
i'm tired well we got a lot of
trilobites let's take them over to the
tables and see what we got
oh
oh that was huge you can see the
skeleton and then the
padding underneath it yeah this is my
best one right there
this one will actually fit in my checked
bag so i think i'll take this one home
oh that's cool i like to get the
symmetry there
so that's the ones you want to bring
home yeah and then the rest i'm giving
to grandma
[Music]
beautiful
butterfly wing effect there well me and
the family had a great time digging up
these fossils
if you guys want to come here to you dig
fossils i'll put a link down in the
video description below
okay goodbye love you love you baby i'll
see you tomorrow well me and jake just
said goodbye to mom and brothers we're
gonna head off into the desert to do
some camping are you ready
yeah we are going to go check out some
cool stuff we
are going to be camping in lava caves
wild horses that's cool
lava rock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here you wanna go check out some lava
tubes why don't you put on your backpack
here okay
look at this look at that
that's crazy you see another lava tube
now don't get too close to the edge okay
yeah that's a huge lava tube
[Music]
the edge can break and fall down
sun's starting to get low we gotta find
our campsite quick
oh give that a sign
go buddy
all right let's go ahead and explore a
little bit
well this ceiling looks pretty solid up
here
and you can see there's no rocks on the
ground so nothing's falling off the
ceiling in a very very long time
so i think this is where we're gonna
make camp all right let's uh
all righty
you know a great thing about sleeping in
a lava tube is you don't have to worry
about staking down your tent
heck the only reason why we're using a
tent here is so that we don't have any
scorpions or snakes or mosquitoes biting
us in the middle of the night
i've seen one and you'll buzz it right
in the house
oh
got our beds all set up should we get
some dinner are you hungry
yeah all right i bet you are there
that looks like that's boiling you want
beef stew
or do you want lasagna
of course you want lasagna
does that taste good bud
yeah you're eating some monsanto
hey did you would you like a roasted
marshmallow
there you go
you like your marshmallow oh there's a
mouse there's a mouse running around the
bottom of the lava tube now i'm glad we
have the dent
there he is that's easy right there guys
he just ran up
everybody let's get ready for bed okay
slide on down buddy yo is that cozy yeah
well other than all the little creature
noises we had a good night's sleep uh
woke up a couple times because i could
hear a mouse chewing on a log and
the bats would come in and make their
little squeaky noise and they'd be
flapping right above the tent
well i'm gonna let jake sleep in as much
as he can because that boy needs his
rest but as soon as he's up we're gonna
need a quick breakfast
and uh then we're gonna go and check out
some really cool stuff
there's some sand dunes and dried lake
beds
and some cool rock features and even
some historical sites nearby
we got a full day of exploring the
desert before we can go back home
good morning jacob
got some blueberry granola with milk
excited for some breakfast
yeah here you go bud
yeah would you like all right should we
go back to the car
do you not want to fall down
we got a couple hours of serious four by
fouring to do
there's just miles and miles of these
lava tube formations i mean more than
you could ever explore
just look at them we can hike for days
out here and never see all of them
[Music]
my two oldest boys tommy and nathan
they're in school still so that's why
it's just
me and jacob camping out today my boys
are stuck at home doing online school
but
uh school's gonna be out here in a week
or two and then we're gonna have the
whole crew
exploring and camping and doing
adventures with us
this whole desert we've been exploring
is part of an
ancient lake called lake bonneville and
it used to be the size of about lake
michigan
and right up there that hill that hill
is an
old volcano and that's what caused the
lava tubes about 15
000 years ago it exploded some pretty
cool geology here in utah
[Applause]
look what i just found
that's a mule deer antler nice one too
you're a deer
oh look at this
what a beautiful place just saw this
little rock formation decided to go up
and check it out i'm so glad i did
all right let's keep moving
it look a little cottontail rabbit
jacob come check this out right up there
there's a big pile of sticks
that's the nest of a golden eagle right
there
see look at that it's a little jaw bone
of some animal
the eagle aid got the bones of little
birds and mice and stuff
from the leftovers from the eagles nest
tell you what that was pretty cool
look at that hey jacob look what we got
ahead we got a dry lake
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's fun
[Music]
i speak sheep
that's the first car we've seen in 24
hours
guys this is the topaz mountain japanese
concentration camp from world war
ii on this location thousands of
japanese
americans from the west coast were taken
from their homes
and relocated to the desert here in utah
and forced
to live under guard and barbed wire for
the duration of world war
ii this is where the internment camp
hospital was
you can see kind of the old roads and
it's all set out in the grid pattern
this thing was the size of a
small town
japanese spies and saboteurs had helped
the japanese attack
pearl harbor so when world war ii
started
the us was afraid that the japanese
spies would do the same thing on the
west coast
so all japanese people whether they were
americans or not
were rounded up and removed from the
west coast
and forced into settlement camps like
this one here
out in the middle of nowhere
as far as your eye can see it's old
abandoned roads and broken
foundations
look at this
[Music]
there's the car all the way down there
[Music]
oh
oh well this is taking a lot more time
than i thought
it's getting late we need to get headed
home
all right we're back did you guys have
fun while i was going
yeah we went at a farm and had a ball
tommy actually took a gopro and did some
videoing at the farm
so we decided to stop by historic
wheeler farm so the kids could see some
animals and run around and play
well we're here exploring the farm while
luke and jacob
are camping
you gonna you want to ride on this yeah
okay
is that a baby donkey yeah i like it
there were so many cows oh man that was
so much fun we're back
nice work i literally just saw a
three car swimming so we're gonna go
meet up with luke and jacob
and go get some dinner
you guys ready to go to dinner
oh good morning it's another wonderful
day and uh the boys are doing their
online school
got a little breakfast made here and a
little bit i'm gonna take jacob and go
run a few errands cause uh we've got
some adventures coming up
and one of the big things i need to do
today is make crawfish traps
all right jake you ready to go to a big
backpacking store
i was looking to buy a specific sleeping
bag and i'm coming here to
backcountry.com
it's one of the biggest outdoor gear
retailers in the country
and their warehouse and retail store are
here in salt lake county
look at this place it is huge all right
all right so what they do is they got
these computers here we go in and search
their entire
website for any of their products and uh
then we tell them they go to the
warehouse and pull it for us so
all right let's see if i got it right
all right there we go it's kind of nice
because there's a lot of high ticket
items i've wanted to buy but
i didn't really want to buy them without
checking them out physically and
touching them first so
come here check them out get them
well tomorrow me and jacob are going to
go on a catch and cook camp out we're
going to try to catch a bunch of
crawfish so
i've got some chicken wire here and i'm
going to go ahead and try to make some
crawfish traps
that we needed to work on then we go and
we squish here is the word
wait do you like cereal yeah
well there we go that's a pillow
crawfish trap takes about four minutes
to make
super cheap and easy we're gonna use
these to catch a lot of crawfish
oh there we go all done this is really
good for you are you excited to go catch
crawfish
yeah all right guys let's get in the car
come on everybody
all right since we're in utah we're
gonna go take the kids down to brigham
young university and show
them me and mama's old stomping grounds
and we're gonna go beat some family for
dinner
all right guys welcome to provo utah
yeah this is all new so that's why
mountain with the big y on it
when i attended byu whenever it would
snow i would go and rent skis and hike
to the top of white mountain and ski
down
buy one follow me now this is nostalgic
because me and becca met at byu
we did yeah the world can blame byu for
those three
byu is a massive private university
it has 34 000 students currently
enrolled here
and it's about 556 acres very compact
very walkable and it's one of the most
affordable
universities in america
when me and becca went to byu as
students she was an excellent student i
was a terrible one
we met when we were both sophomores and
by the time i graduated
she'd been teaching here for three years
with her masters a lot of people go to
college for seven years
i know they're called doctors
[Music]
that's uh where they filmed byu tv and
studio c was filmed
carolina can mess up this shop
that's a kodiak grizzly bear you've got
to feed these huh
there's a tiger
there's a crocodile yeah
look at this tiny thing oh check it out
it's a liger
what's a liger it's pretty much my
favorite animal
it's like a lion and a tiger mixed
breadford's skills and magic
american alligator we we ate one of
those this is a buffalo and remember
we've slept on the buffalo hides
next door
did you want any ice cream
let's get some ice cream
that looks awesome
oh my goodness fluff and butter it's
graham cracker caramel and marshmallow
right
peanut butter too oh and peanut butter
you like your chocolate
he was pretending to shoot you oh that's
where mommy and daddy met right there
hey guys look at playground do you want
to play in a playground
okay okay okay i bought it over i'll
pull it up
all the things we do all the adventures
we go on
they like this more
let's go have dinners with cousins shall
we
we're just sitting here at a mexican
restaurant with my niece
and my nephew spencer both of them are
down here in college from alaska
just having a nice nice day i need a
food
you need a poop and spencer's friend
here is eating the largest burrito in
the world
what is so big that is that is huge
i can help with that i can help well
gwynna thanks for coming
of course all right
all right it's past your bedtime guys we
gotta get home get you to bed
well guys it is a nice relaxing day i'm
sitting here
editing up videos and the boys are doing
more online school tomorrow's the last
day of school so
almost there
oh i love cooking there we go
yeah don't eat toenails before lunch
buddy is still ruin your dinner i put it
with ice cream before now it's how do i
no
all right guys you ready to go to the
museum in antelope island and stuff
zombie you excited yeah i recognize some
of these games
some of these planes well tommy's pretty
excited about airplanes lately so we're
here at the hill
air force base air museum
f-117 that's cool
that's the gatling gun look at the size
of that bullet maybe that girl's stuff
oh yeah
[Music]
these are nuclear bombs that's a replica
of the first atomic bomb ever
this is like a dream come true
well we're headed out to antelope island
which is in the great
salt lake and uh so we're gonna go check
it out maybe see some bison
you can see where the water's all
receded the water used to be all the way
up to the causeway
and in case you're wondering the great
salt lake smells like nathan's farts
not good
if you want to go swimming in the great
stinky salt lake you can do that
but it's the water's receded so much you
got to hike
pretty far ways before you get to the
water and then you have to wait out even
further before you get deep enough to be
able to
sit down in it a big one
all right guys who wants to eat a
buffalo burger
me take a bunch of bites
try the buffalo breaker becca tastes
like a bird yeah
you want a giant corn dog bud
there's a buffalo on the side of the
road
well after antelope island we got the
kids back to the house and in bed and me
and becca are going on a date
we're doing some fine dining it's been
all right guys we're here at log haven
in mill creek canyon and but look at
this scenery
beautiful place
we got our appetizer korean fried
cauliflower oh my goodness
okay that cauliflower was amazing
i am so gonna figure that recipe out and
try that at home
oh becca that is quite the meal look at
those pork chops and bacon brussels
sprouts
i've got an elk steak with a current jam
and what looks like
couscous that is so good
good i really like the bacon brussels
sprouts
they're really good babe did you enjoy
that i loved it that food was great
the company was the only thing better
than the food
let's go
all right jacob we're here
we're in the uinta mountains of utah and
we
are going to kayak out to that island
where we're going to be
fishing catching crawfish and camping
oh this water is crystal clear
look at that
[Music]
we're here yeah
first thing we're gonna do today is set
out our crawfish traps and i've got
these baby carp here and we're gonna
chop those up
and use those as bait we also have some
chicken legs as bait
[Music]
okay all right we got each trap set with
a piece of chicken and a piece of carp
we're gonna go see if we can't catch
some crawfish
we should be able to see them in the
rocks
oh there's one see him see he's oh
there's a bunch of them right there
okay
you ready jake yeah you know throw it
throw it out there
there you go all right we got all the
crawfish traps set
and some of them are just covered in
crawfish already and
i think we're gonna catch a lot of
crawfish
all right bud hop on out
uh-oh i think i pitched the tent on top
of my cooking pot
yep that's right
jake you want a fish yeah all right you
you got the vinyl arms
yeah i'm gonna put it right here
so i got my rod set up in these bite
alarms anything comes and hits it
makes a nice loud beep so me and jake
can mess around with our stuff and if a
fish comes along and bites we're going
to hear it
well i've got a little boy who is
hounding me to go check the crawfish
traps
isn't that right buddy you want to go
check the crawfish traps
they've only been soaking for about an
hour but it'll give us a good idea of
which locations they're producing and
which ones aren't
okay pull it grab that bottle
pull the string up high five fast pull
it up pull up oh i see him
i see him see pull up the traps look at
the trims
we have something look at this look at
this some nice ones too
all right look at this here we
what you go is grab the bottle and you
got to
pull it up quickly you pull them up
throw it over there right there all
right
another crawfish
[Music]
that's a few of them i'll do a little
snack
here do you see them
almost yeah they're so armored look at
this
yeah look at these hey see if you grab
them behind the shoulders they can't
pinch you
unless of course you're doing a crawfish
fight
hey look at this he's pinched you let go
of him see
he's pinched your life jacket see that's
why you always wear a life jacket while
crawfishing
here watch i got it you
you don't mind picking them up do you
yeah
yeah that lobster
yeah throw them in there there you go
there we go
all right you ready to eat some crawfish
yeah anything that's crunchy you just
remove
now there you go a little bit of tail
meat
jake you want to try that yeah
you're really hardcore you suck the
mustard out of the head
good that's the freshest seafood you'll
find in utah
you wanna you wanna eat the corn
that's their poop
inside we're eating their butts i'd like
to catch a ton of crawfish on this trip
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
let the trap soak
until right about bedtime then we're
going to go on the kayak and pull the
traps
re-bait them throw them out and uh
hopefully tomorrow morning we're going
to have a ton
of crawfish but we got a couple hours
before bedtime so i think
me and jake should digest in the tent
and watch some cartoons
sit down and we'll take your boots off
so you don't get your boots on the on
the sleeping bags
you're an earthworm yeah
oh we got a fish
oh look at this what a
lovely trout look at that
that is a nice healthy fish i think we
need to have some trout with our
crawfish
huh that is a nice fish look at that
well that's awesome i want to go catch
some more of those we're going to eat
the truck tomorrow and i want to keep it
alive until then
so i grabbed one of my crawfish traps to
put the trout inside it
and uh man look at this we are
loaded so i'm just gonna take the trap
so there we go
oh there you go
that should work there's a fish a fish
oh look at it oh look at that beautiful
sucker
oh you put up a better fight than that
rainbow
what a beautiful fish but uh i gotta eat
them so
let's
oh that was awesome camping with jacob
on a beautiful day
kayaking catching crawfish catching fish
it's nice all right the sun's almost set
we're gonna go pull all of our crawfish
traps and re-bait them and
see what we got
oh yeah we got some a few we got a few
in there
throw back in the fish
oh look at this there's even one on the
string
[Music]
only one
got another five
but throw it in there you go
we pulled six traps we baited them and
the sun's about to set so
we're gonna head back to camp and uh get
ready for the night
oh yeah look at that
got a good pile of crawfish there
i accidentally ran over this with the
kayak and the trout got out
all right buddy hop into your bed okay
it's supposed to be in the 30s tonight
so uh we'll see how we do
but i think we'll be we'll be in pretty
good shape
so scary i'm a human oh
thank goodness well i'll tell you what
guys it is no joke cold right now and it
is getting
colder i am using every bit of this
sleeping bag and i'm
considering putting on some hand warmers
or a fleece it's cold
we'll see we'll see how it goes but oh
i just realized if i hook a fish i'm
gonna have to get out of my sleeping bag
i just had another fish on and lost it
but it's uh
time to go to bed so i'm gonna reel it
in and uh get snuggled in my bag
it's so cold out here
meanwhile well here we are we're at my
folks cabin well
while luke and jacob are camping at
strawberry reservoir working at camp
rebecca tommy nathan here with the loot
outdoor boys youtube channel are we
ready to do this
yeah we're going to be having an awesome
time
getting up cowboy
well guys you want to eat some pizza why
are you okay
while the boys are on the four-wheeler
with grandpa i get to do a quick
watercolor sketch
i'm not done and i have to work fast
because i'm losing my light but it's fun
it's a little break i have to discard
okay it's your tweet
and a full good night boys
see you in the morning the next day
oh good morning it is a beautiful
beautiful day i can hear little man
starting to stir
in the tent
hey good morning jake
you sleep well last night you stay warm
good what would you rather do first eat
breakfast
or check the crawfish traps
i thought i'd do the answer today gonna
go get crawfish in our jammies
how cool is that
oh look how many there are in here
oh man there was like 20 in that one
there we go you did pretty good bud
oh this one is pretty good oh
beautiful and calm today exactly what we
need
well there we go that's that's not bad
i mean that's a meal right there some
nice ones
you want breakfast how about blueberry
granola you okay with that
home
well i called my wife and my in-laws to
tell them that we got some crawfish
etouffee coming their way
and all of them gave me a resounding no
thank you
so we're gonna let all the crawfish go
those are cool what a neat place
but uh we're gonna go home and go see
mama
i'm sorry buddy you okay yeah
okay well i'm gonna do it again but i'm
gonna try again but this time daddy's
gonna be more careful how about you
go in dad then i'm going
see was that better
if you're soggy and you know it clap
your hands
is it funny that daddy wet his pants
yeah no
oh where that's it we're on the bottom
here i'll get out
there you go bud jake did you have a fun
time yeah
even though i dumped you in the water
yeah well we made it back to the house
and my oldest boys are done with school
so
it is the beginning of summer break for
our whole family
i want to just be hanging out at the
house for the rest of the day i got a
bunch of editing to do
but uh we've got some more adventures to
do
but this time we get to bring the whole
family you know what time it is
yeah it is taking a little editing break
to make some fajitas
oh yeah
you like your fijita you're so scared
well now we've got a little food in us
we're gonna go up to a little mountain
lake and do a little walk around
over 100 degrees down the valley and
there's a patch of snow
yeah it's open
and soft all right you ready to go on
another date becca
yeah all right let's go get some dinner
we're going to a place called tiberon
pork belly and some onions and some brie
nice
oh mango what do you got there it's
chicken with
liquids look at that lamb with a
blueberry reduction
oh my goodness that was
delicious stick with me baby you'll get
fat
well it's been a lovely low-key day but
we gotta go inside
face the music and put our kids to bed
so we'll see you guys in the morning
we're gonna change things up a little
bit and do something different
becca's going scuba diving
all right guys here's the homestead
crater it's this big
mineral deposit makes a hollow dome
and inside is a heated hot spring and
we're going to go
snorkeling and scuba diving inside
for a long time
this thing is deep i think it's like
over 60 feet deep
and it's always around 90 something
degrees it's warm in here
this is the deepest water you've ever
swam in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
bro you guys want to get out maybe go
find a soda or ice cream or something
you guys want to go to a bakery yeah
there's a place over here that sells
pistachio eclairs
and it's closing soon so we're going to
try to go get one for becca before she's
done with her scuba class
[Music]
oh that's it nowadays
okay
[Music]
what do you think of that tom like that
that actually is not called ice cream
that's called gelato
did you have fun with your scuba class i
had a great time it was really fun oh
great
i'm glad you had a good time i did you
look good looks like you know what
you're doing oh
very bubbly
scuba diving mama i did it hey jacob was
it scary when mommy went underwater
yeah yeah nothing like scuba diving to
work up an appetite huh becca
you'll still have to help oh my goodness
you'll have to help me though this is
huge
well guys we've got a lot of leftovers
it's been a great day but we're going to
hit the sack get the boys to bed and
i'll see you guys in the morning
well guys it's another lovely low-key
day here in utah and we're just hanging
out at the
cabin and i'm doing editing and the kids
are riding on four-wheelers and
becca's gonna do some painting
nathan grab a plate grab your food and
they play football in florida in florida
do you guys like mom to come camping
with us
[Music]
all right guys well we had a lovely time
but we are packing up the car and
heading down out of the canyon because
we
are going to a drive-in movie ah
we're doing our very first drive-in
theater here and it's
ridiculously affordable it's 10 bucks
for an adult one dollar for kids
jacob's free so 22 bucks our whole
family is doing a saturday night movie
they got the parking lots slanted up so
you could angle the car
just like that we're gonna fold down the
back seats get out the
the camping gear and the pizza and the
kids are gonna sit here and watch movies
up past their bedtime
wait did you guys want some snacks yeah
oh i might have got some
popcorn grab that
mmm liking those huh yeah
good as i remember this this is nice i
wish we could do this every weekend
all right so we just tuned the radio to
95.9
and once the movie starts we should be
able to hear the audio
over the car speakers
[Music]
so tommy what do you think you like that
it was awesome
well guys welcome to another beautiful
day and we're all in the car
ready to go in another desert camping
adventure
all right guys we're here at bicknell
utah at the
glow motel and cafe where they have the
famous
pickle and pinto bean pies so we ordered
like
six different slices of pie here and
we're gonna try all the different
flavors plus a couple traditional ones
and uh get some lunch
pinto bean pie buttermilk pie pickle pie
and oatmeal pie we're going to try a
little bit of each i'm going to try the
pickle one first
that is really good it tastes a lot like
a very sweet pumpkin pie
you want to try the pickle pie yeah
you like that daddy
pumpkin pie doesn't it good i'm gonna
try the
the pinto
that bean pie is really good it tastes
like a coconut cream pie
almost but with like a mild flavored
anko or azuki bean in it
the oatmeal pie is good if you like
oatmeal cookies
this is a buttermilk why it is oh the
buttermilk is almost like a lemon
meringue pie if you took out all the
lemon flavor
that's good smooth bean and buttermilk
are my favorites
what's your favorite so far buttermilk
or bean all right we got a good
old-fashioned
blueberry aloe mode and strawberry aloe
mode oh
oh so many leftovers we're gonna have to
go on a big hike to work off all that
pie guys
[Music]
look guys there's cows everywhere
[Music]
check it out it's one of the few places
where you'll have a cliff
on both sides of the road but we are now
in
escalante national monument and check
out this view
look at these canyons holy mackerel
escalante national monument is kind of
the
unknown hidden gem in southern utah
but if you want to get away from the
crowds this is the place to do it
[Music]
so
[Music]
keep walking guys we're in the desert
now the temperature is a blistering 93
degrees
and uh we're going on a 3.2 mile hike to
a couple of slot canyons
i have no clue whether we'll make it or
not
mutiny is a little bit in the air right
now we're going to the peekaboo slot
canyon and spooky slot canyon which if
you
are new to hiking and new to
canyoneering
these are great places to start the only
way i convinced tommy to come along is i
told him there's a good chance we might
see some lizards
all right we've been hiking for only
eight minutes and tommy's asking if
we're there yet and nathan wants to take
a break
this is not a good sign
[Music]
hey look at this guys it's cow poop
do you see there's no there's not much
firewood around yeah so they'd use
buffalo poop and cow poop
as their fire here here tom
are you tired okay i got something
that'll help you out okay
run i'm gonna throw rocks at you
run faster you do nathan ah
that dead run we're having family
bonding time
how you doing becca
there's the slot canyon right there
well we came to the spot in the trail
where there's a bit of vertical
and uh the crew decided no so
we're gonna go see something else well
i'm a little disappointed we didn't make
it all the way to the sly canyon
but honestly i'm just really excited
becca's going camping with us so i
really don't care
well we didn't quite get the hike done
but at least this gives us a little bit
more time to see a few things
and to get camp set up in the daylight
so because we
are taking mama camping
all right this is the devil's garden
let's check it out
that's cool and nice nice do you see me
beautiful train
i would live here it goes way back there
for quite a ways there's a lot of these
formations
this is cool wasn't it
all right i've got my two-man z-pac tent
and we've got
all three boys gonna be fitting in here
and i'm just gonna cover them up with
two of these camping quilts
all right becca gets my therm-a-rest
mundo key and my camping quilt
and i'm gonna take the air mattress and
the yeti sleeping bag
yeah hey guys how do you like that
dinner
it's good thank you well guys it's late
the kids are in bed where everyone's fed
we'll see you guys in the morning thanks
for coming camping with me
good morning good morning yeah i did
okay
it was i was warm i really liked the
camping globe
good morning you got a good night's rest
oh yeah
it felt like 90 degrees last night
it was perfect that boy likes it hot
[Music]
becky get a little painting done a
little bit a little quick sketch
it was fast thanks for waiting for me
beautiful place
all right guys you ready to go to goblin
valley
we're going to go to goblin valley you
want to go
oh it's super scary
well that was just a fun little family
camp out and honestly the highlight
is the drive going down route 12 through
escalante
is one of the most scenic roads in all
of utah we're really close to bryce
canyon
capitol reef zions arches canyonlands
there's
amazing national parks all over the
place
but a lot of those are really crowded
and frankly me and becca have been to
all of those
several times so we want to try
something new so we're going to go up to
goblin valley and the kids are really
excited to see goblins
they only eat children don't worry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right there's near frida utah and
there's a bunch of petroglyphs up on the
cliffs see right up there on the cliffs
there's little drawings of people and
stuff
there's actually places all over utah
you can see ancient petroglyphs like
this
and a lot of them you can get a lot
closer uh over in vernal
nine mile canyon and a few other places
between here and salt lake see them up
there
see that one it's like 88 degrees
outside
you want to take this off we like heat
stroke there you go
hey guys you want to do a little
off-roading yeah all right let's do some
off-roading
if you like off-roading there's plenty
of places to do it here in utah
look at this well this is pretty cool
but should we keep going to goblin
valley
yeah all right let's go to goblin valley
welcome to goblin valley state park a
ton of stuff to do here but uh
we're overheated and lazy so we're just
gonna drive through
and enjoy it from the car with the ac on
all right guys here you go this is
goblin valley and of course the little
rock formations looked kind of like
goblins so
that's how you got the name jacob says
he threw one of his shoes out the car
so he's only got one shoe on so i get to
carry him today
this place looks like the rock planet
from galaxy quest
[Music]
don't open that it's an alien planet is
there air
you don't know oh
that's like what 95 93 degrees right now
it's hot oh geez i did not mean to jump
onto this rock
you guys having fun yeah look at this
place goes on forever
there's a lot more to see here than just
goblin valley there's a lot of arches
and camping and there's even some really
awesome hikes and slot canyons
but as of yesterday my family's adopted
a no
hiking policy so we're gonna get back in
the car and turn on the ac
oh if you were a desert fox you would
live here yeah oh
that was cool but hot that sun just
bakes that rock and you get down in
there and it's like being in a solar
oven
rebecca are you ready to do another date
you are you in the mood for some italian
food babe
i love it i love italian food
all right becca we got some more food
here huh some cheeses and some focaccia
and some chili jam there that looks nice
cheese
there's i think there's some candied
pecans in here what do you got chicken
piccata
filet mignon
becca did you have a good day have a
great day thank you
it's always a good day when it's with
you well listen it's late guys i gotta
go put kids to bed
i'll see you guys in the morning
hi dad
c3 okay we're good on this one have you
had a good time at grandma grandpa's
house
are you sad to leave well guys good
morning
and goodbye it's the end of our trip
here in utah and we're packing up and
weighing the luggage
and getting ready to head out the
airport we've had a great time
and we hope you've enjoyed this video
but if you guys want to see more
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel check out
our travel adventure playlist with all
of our travel around the world
and don't forget to click subscribe
because we put out new videos every
saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching